Susan's with us Susan's in Florida hi
Susan how are you hi Dave I'm great how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well my husband and I realized a few
months ago that we needed to clean up
our debt so I started I got a copy of
Total Money Makeover and reading through
it and I'm looking on getting that
budget put together and I'm really ready
to dive right in and start cutting
expenses and get going on this on the
steps but my husband's for me to be a
little reluctant to change the current
lifestyle and everything I'm just
wondering how I can convince him well
what kind of tact I should take and
convince him that we should start
thinking long term so the short term is
he looking at the budget yeah I've been
showing him what I've been doing and you
know what our expenses are what our
income is and showing him how to break
it down into all the different expenses
but you know he's used to certain give
me a certain amount of money out of the
bank for his pocket money each week and
he just doesn't seem to want to think
about changing and how much he's
spending
okay well you know some version of this
and I'll use the sarcastic version okay
but some version of this is honey I
don't I want to be married to like a man
that walks with me I don't be your mommy
giving you an allowance every week and
you whining if it's not enough so you're
gonna sit down here with me and we're
gonna go through this budget together
like we're two grownups and we as a
couple are gonna decide on our future
you get a vote and I get a vote and then
we one side based on that what we're
each getting for pocket money but this
you know I'm not your mother
right and that's how it's grown
reluctant to you know say no to his
spending sometimes because I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna not I'm never gonna say no
to his spending again I'm not going to
accept that he is not participating in
deciding the whole process where we
agree together okay
you're not his mother
right you quit being his mother stop it
he needs to man up here and be a part of
the equation where we make our decisions
so our bills are paid and so we have a
good future now we can have a discussion
about the path of what that is but mommy
I don't want to buy something and you
won't let me buy something
well why you little boy let's go stop
let's gonna drive you crazy you're gonna
get tired of that you're already tired
of it how old is this guy look look 42
okay and in the household he grew up in
his mother handled the money and his dad
brought it in so that's what was
marvelous
that's what was modeled in front of him
and it's a toxic bad model working
together as two adults making decisions
together on what we're going to enjoy
what we're going to give what we're
going to sacrifice what we're going to
invest for our common goals that we both
agree on which includes enjoyment and
spending but also includes thinking
together is a grown-up couple with good
mental health but you can't you can't be
his mommy anymore it's got to stop
you're gonna get real tired of that I
mean it's gonna and he's gotten away
with it for a long time so it's gonna be
little heartbreak but just go through I
don't be your mom anymore I'm not gonna
be your mother anymore I'm not gonna do
it I'm not your mommy
I'm not your mommy don't ask me for
money I'm not your mommy get in here and
man freaking up and you know again I'm
just giving you a sarcastic version but
you got to keep turning up that heat
until he hears that honey I need you to
be a man I need you to sit down here at
the kitchen table as my man and walk
with me and we make these decisions
together as two grown-up adults I'm not
going to be a little princess where I'm
whining about what I can't spend and
you're not gonna be little lord
fauntleroy over here asking his mommy
for money anymore I'm done with this and
some version of that fight has to occur
and it can be pleasant or unpleasant
gentle
not gentle I don't know what it takes at
your house we're hillbillies we fight
pretty hard at our house but at some
point you got a man up here it's growing
up
whether you're 52 42 or 22 it's I'm
taking control of my destiny I'm gonna
take this chaos and I'm gonna take I'm
gonna bring order out of this chaos and
I'm gonna do it as a grown-up oh and by
the way there's two of us here so we're
both gonna do it as grown-ups
[Music]